so there are people in this world to use
gas stoves for a living and one of them
is Stratos morphogen who runs a
restaurant owns a restaurant he's the
author of be a disrupter he joins us to
assess stress thanks so much for coming
on so you're a restaurant owner this is
not a luxury item to you this is core to
your business
first of all would you obey a ban on gas
stoves and second why are they Superior
to Electric you know what it is Tucker
for people that don't understand the
restaurant industry for 35 years we've
been attacked by everybody we had
organized crime in our industry 30 in
the 70s 80s and 90s in the 2000s we had
corrupt Wall Street and for the last
three years we've had government
overreach I mean we've seen it during
govid they did things they never
followed the science and what's going on
what I heard I heard the rumor about
this last year and what I'm hearing
about today from the White House to
Governor hokel that they want to redo
they want to make us for new restaurant
construction use electric stoves so let
me explain it to you we lose 40 percent
productivity by using electric
by using electric if they ever inquired
with small business owners I'll give
them three pieces of advice get stronger
filtration system get a hood system that
works and basically train your staff on
how to maintain it
but for 35 years we continuously have
obstacles in running our industry and I
got to tell you Tucker and I want to
thank you for supporting small business
since the last time I was on you
inspired me to write the book and I got
to tell you because our journey is
constantly being attacked like we're
vulnerable and this is creme de La Creme
because I will tell you this will
destroy our industry just as bad as they
attempted to do with covid
I mean there's got to be a limit to what
people are going to put up with there
has to be a red line I would I would
counsel Mass disobedience in the face of
tyranny in this case I mean do you think
restaurant owners would obey why does
Kathy hokel have a right to tell you
what kind of stove you have she's an
idiot yeah I I like listen I didn't obey
Kathy Holcomb with any of the mandates
like and I'm not going to obey Kathy
hokel now because let me tell you
something with electric stoves first of
all my bills will go six times higher
and then then on top of that our
productivity drops this isn't just going
to hurt the restaurant hospitality
industry it's going to hurt real estate
development remember casinos shopping
malls airports uh residential Towers
Office Buildings they depend on us for
the content and if we don't develop the
content for these big you know this is
our industry for these big developers
well guess what this whole thing will
collapse there makes again they're not
following science and this is not
following science there are so many
other ways like we do we don't allow our
Cooks to basically stand in Smoke we
have a strong filtration smoke
evacuation system and this is what's
needed if they want to go down this
route
the idea that people who sent crack
pipes to drug addicts are concerned
about safety is like the most hilarious
thing I've ever heard in my life ignore
them please so that's more [ __ ] great
to see you tonight thank you thank you
so thank you so much Tucker subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight